Добрий день. Мене звати Ігор Гольдштейн.
Я вчитель математики
київської школи «Базис».
Наш перший урок буде
присвячений комбінаториці.
Скількома способами можна
скласти список учнів вашого класу?
Скільки існує п’ятицифрових чисел,
які задовольняють певним умовам?
Скільки діагоналей у
опуклого п’ятикутника?
І так далі, і так далі, і так далі …
Ми весь час маємо розв’язувати
якісь задачі на підрахунок варіантів.
Розділ математики, який цим займається,
який дає нам інструменти для такого
підрахунку, називається комбінаторика.
Отже, ми починаємо комбінаторику.
Основні правила комбінаторики буду
показувати за допомогою прикладів.
Задача.
Турист планує зробити подорож з міста “А“
в місто “С“ по дорозі
відвідавши місто “В“.
З міста “А“ в місто “В“ веде 7 шляхів,
з міста “В“ у місто “С“ веде 10 шляхів.
Скількома способами він
може скласти свій маршрут?
Давайте міркувати.
Перша його дія – він обирає
шлях з міста “А“ в місто “В“.
Припустимо, він обрав якийсь шлях.
Для такого шляху
далі є десять варіантів –
він може обрати десять способів
продовжити свою мандрівку.
Другий шлях він обере – для
нього буде також десять способів.
Ми сім разів беремо по десять способів.
7 на 10, зрозуміло, 70.
Я проілюстрував правило, яке
називається правилом множення.
Якщо якусь дію ми можемо
виконати “М“ способами,
для наступної за нею дії при кожному
варіанті ми можемо обрати “К“ способи.
Можливість зробити ці дві дії
послідовно буде - “М“ помножити на “К“.
Це називається правило множення.
Давайте розглянемо наступну задачу.
Знов таки, мандрівник хоче розробити
маршрут з міста “А“ в місто “С“,
тільки він з’ясував, що існує ще
можливість піти через місто “D“.
І він буде думати – піти через
місто “В“ чи через місто “D“.
З міста “А“ до міста “D“
веде, нехай, 5 шляхів,
з міста “D“ до міста “C“ – 4 шляхи.
Скількома способами мандрівник може
розробити маршрут з міста “А“ в місто “С“?
Всі можливі варіанти складення
маршруту розбиваються на дві групи:
- через місто “В“ у нас
варіантів – 7 помножити на 10;
- через місто “D“ у нас
варіантів – 5 помножити на 4.
І, зрозуміло, що не існує
варіантів, які проходять одночасно,
при наших потребах, які ми висловили,
які проходять одночасно і
через місто “В“, і через місто “D“.
Тому ми маємо це додати.
Відповідь – 90.
Ці два основних правила: правило
множення та правило додавання
ми будемо далі використовувати
для розв’язування різних задач.
Перший урок у нас сьогодні
буде присвячений використанню
правил комбінаторики для
розв’язування комбінаторних задач.
Отже, почнемо!
Перша задача.
Простенька задача – а скільки
існує п’ятицифрових чисел?
Зрозуміло, що можна написати
найменше п’ятицифрове число,
можна написати найбільше
п’ятицифрове число,
порахувати – скільки тоді між ними;
віднімаючи, не забудемо
там додати одиничку.
Але зараз ми поговоримо
про інші способи –
як такі речі розв’язуються за
допомогою правил комбінаторики?
Я кажу, у нас існує 10 цифр.
На перше місце ми можемо
поставити будь-яку з цифр, звісно, крім 0
перша цифра запису натуральних
чисел не може дорівнювати нулю.
Отже, на перше місце я
можу обрати будь-яку з 9 цифр.
На друге місце – обмежень ніяких
немає, тут 10 цифр, 10, 10, 10.
За основним правилом
комбінаторики це треба перемножити
і ми з вами одержимо результат – існує
дев’яносто тисяч п’ятицифрових чисел.
Гаразд, далі будемо трішки
ускладнювати наші задачі.
Наступна задача, подивіться,
будь ласка, на екран
– скільки існує п’ятицифрович
чисел, всі цифри в запису яких парні?
Давайте зробимо аналогічним чином.
Цифр у нас всього 10,
серед них, рівно 5 – парні.
І, знов таки, на перше місце я можу
поставити будь-яку цифру крім 0.
Тобто, в мене існує чотири варіанти.
На кожне з наступних місць
існує п’ять варіантів вибору цифр.
За правилом множення ці числа треба
перемножити і ми одержимо відповідь.
Наступна задача.
Скільки існує п’ятицифрових чисел, в
запису яких існує хоча б одна парна цифра?
Робити цю задачу в лоб не зовсім легко,
ми маємо перебирати багато варіантів:
може бути одна парна цифра,
може бути дві, три, чотири, п’ять.
Для кожного з цих варіантів треба
теж якось влаштовувати підрахунок.
А ми зараз спростимо.
Підказкою я хотів би, щоб ви
запам’ятали оце словосполучення:
“хоча б” або “принаймні”.
Це сигнал для того, що можна
використовувати трішки інший метод.
Метод інший полягає в тому, що замість
підрахунку варіантів, які нас влаштовують,
буває набагато зручніше рахувати
варіанти, які нас не влаштовують.
Значить, нас цікавлять числа, в запису
яких присутня хоча б одна парна цифра.
Які числа, давайте запитаємо
себе, нас не влаштовують?
Відповідно, нас не влаштовують
числа, в запису яких парних цифр немає.
Парних цифр немає – це
означає, що вони всі – непарні.
А тепер давайте тоді ще раз:
п’ятицифрових чисел, всіх можливих, ми
порахували раніше – дев’яносто тисяч.
П’ятицифрових чисел,
які нас не влаштовують –
це ті, в запису яких присутні
тільки непарні цифри:
п’ять варіантів, п’ять
варіантів … і п’ять варіантів.
Отже, їх п’ять у п’ятому.
Насправді – 3125, але це, в
даному випадку, неважливо.
Отже, наша відповідь –
від кількості всіх п’ятицифрових чисел
ми віднімаємо ті, які нас не влаштовують.
Скільки там це буде – 86875,
але насправді конкретне
число тут не має значення.
Отже, наступна задача.
Скільки п’ятицифрових
чисел, які діляться на п’ять,
можна записати використовуючи не більше
одного разу числа з набору від 0 до 5?
Нагадаю ознаку подільності на 5 –
число ділиться на 5 тоді і лише тоді,
коли його остання цифра ділиться на 5.
Тобто, вона є або нулем, або п’ятіркою.
Як рахувати?
Коли остання цифра 5 – у нас
буде обмеження на першу цифру,
вона не може бути нулем.
Коли остання цифра 0 – у
нас не буде таких обмежень.
Що робити?
Ми, як і у випадку з маршрутами, розіб’ємо
всі можливі варіанти на дві групи.
Перша група – це будуть
числа, які закінчуються на 0.
Друга група – це будуть
числа, які закінчуються на 5.
Ми їх порахуємо окремо,
очевидно – не існує чисел, які
закінчуються одночасно на 0 і на 5.
Якщо остання цифра 0 – у нас немає
ніяких обмежень на першу цифру.
Ми її обираємо будь-яку з
набору від одного до п’яти.
У нас п’ять варіантів.
Якщо ця цифра вже обрана,
на друге місце ми можемо поставити
будь-яку цифру крім першої та нуля.
Тобто, залишається
чотири варіанти, три, два.
Ми ці числа перемножимо.
Я сьогодні не буду в кожній задачі
доводити до остаточної відповіді,
бо конкретне число
нам, насправді, не цікаво.
Нам цікаво шлях – як ці числа знаходити.
Якщо ж остання цифра 5?
На перше місце ми можемо поставити
тепер будь яку цифру,
тільки крім п’ятірки та нуля.
Тому тут у нас залишається
чотири варіанти.
Якщо перша цифра обрана,
на друге місце ми тепер
можемо поставити будь яку цифру
крім п’ятірки та першої цифри.
Тобто, знову чотири варіанти.
Наступне місце – крім п’ятірки та
перших двох: три варіанти, два варіанти.
Відповідно, тепер ці
два числа треба додати.
І ми одержимо відповідь, яку ми
зараз з вами рахувати не будемо.
Бо, повторюю, конкретне значення
цього числа нам не є зараз важливим.
Наступна задача.
Від чисел ми тепер
перейдемо до інших об’єктів.
Наступна задача:
скількома способами на
шахову дошку можна поставити
чорну та білу тури так,
щоб вони не били одна одну?
Хочу нагадати, що за
правилами гри в шахи,
дві тури б’ють одна одну
якщо вони знаходяться
або в одному рядочку,
або в одному стовпчику.
Давайте розв’язувати.
Я пропоную робити це наступним
чином – ставити тури послідовно.
Уявляємо собі шахову дошку, дошка 8 на 8.
Зрозуміло, якщо я оберу,
припустимо, чорну туру
і захочу її кудись поставити, в мене
для цього існує 64 варіанти вибору клітин.
Тепер давайте припустимо,
що чорна тура вже стоїть на місці.
Скільки в мене є способів обрати клітинку
для того, щоб поставити туди білу туру?
Чорна тура, коли ми її поставили,
забороняє ставити наступну туру
в будь-яку клітинку в цьому
ж рядочку і в цьому стовпчику.
Неважко порахувати, що чорна
тура, після того як ми її поставили,
забороняє далі 15 клітинок для білої:
не можна поставити в ту саму клітинку,
ще 7 клітинок в тому самому рядочку
і ще 7 клітинок в тому самому стовпчику.
Отже, для білої тури
залишається 49 варіантів.
За правилом множення ми маємо ці
числа перемножити і ми одержимо результат.
Між іншим, число 49 можна було
одержати трішки іншим способом –
уявимо собі, що коли ми ставимо чорну
туру, вона викреслює повністю стовпчик,
викреслює повністю рядочок,
а ті частинки, які залишились, очевидно –
можна зсунути таким чином
щоб утворився квадратик 7 на 7.
Тому для білої тури залишається 49
варіантів. Це є відповідь цієї задачі.
Наступна задача і я спеціально не
прибираю результат попередньої.
Тепер нас цікавить:
скількома способами можна поставити
на шахову дошку дві білих тури так,
щоб вони не били одна одну?
Так, я знаю, що за правилами
шахів, білі тури не б’ють одна одну.
Але ми граємо зараз не в шахи.
Ще раз – умова задачі.
Або, давайте, так сформулюємо:
скількома способами можна поставити
на шахову дошку дві білих тури так,
щоб вони не стояли ані в одному
рядочку, ані в одному стовпчику?
Перше питання, яке виникає – чим ця
задача відрізняється від попередньої?
В чому різниця?
Нібито та сама має бути відповідь.
А от тут ми з вами переходимо
до трішки нової історії,
бо тепер ми з вами можемо
рахувати якісь об’єкти.
Вони можуть повторюватись.
В чому відмінність?
Нехай в попередній задачі я обрав дві
клітинки,
які задовольняють умові задачі.
І в ці дві клітинки я можу поставити:
сюди – чорну туру, сюди – білу.
А можу поставити сюди –
білу туру, а сюди – чорну.
В першій задачі – це
було два різних варіанти.
Тепер, коли ми з вами
працюємо з двома білими турами,
це вже один і той самий варіант.
Виходить, що тепер, якщо ми хочемо
цю задачу зробити через попередню,
то, виходить, що кожен варіант
у нас врахований рівно двічі.
І тому відповідь задачі про дві білих тури
може бути одержана наступним чином –
варіантів рівно вдвічі менше,
тому що в попередній задачі кожен варіант
з нової задачі повторювався рівно двічі.
Це дуже важлива історія,
бо коли ми рахуємо
якісь речі в комбінаториці,
то важливо слідкувати за тим,
щоб наші об’єкти не повторювались.
Наступна задача.
Турнір. Шаховий турнір,
грають п’ять шахістів.
Кожен зіграв з кожним рівно один раз.
Скільки було зіграно партій?
Зрозуміло, що можна рахувати
– перший зіграв чотири партії,
другий – теж зіграв чотири,
але одну ми вже порахували.
Тоді треба додати три і так далі.
Всі ці числа додамо –
одержимо правильну відповідь.
А якщо я запитаю про сто шахістів?
А якщо я запитаю про
будь-яке інше велике число?
Такими підрахунками ми вже не
впораємось, треба шукати щось інше.
Пропоную наступним чином.
Якщо в нас, давайте, все таки,
повернемось до випадку - п’ять шахістів.
Кожен шахіст зіграв рівно чотири партії.
П’ять шахістів, кожен
зіграв рівно чотири партії.
Зрозуміло, що це можна перемножити.
А от корисно порахувати
чи є в нас повтори?
Вони, очевидно, є.
Кожну партію ми порахували рівно двічі,
тому що, якщо іван зіграв з Миколою,
то цю партію ми порахували
і коли рахували партію Івана,
і коли рахували партію Миколи.
Кожна партія врахована рівно двічі,
тому для правильної
відповіді треба поділити навпіл.
Наступна задачка.
Дев’ятиповерховий будинок.
На першому поверсі в
ліфт сідають п’ятеро людей.
Кожен з них виходить на якомусь
випадковому поверсі, будь-якому з 2 по 9.
Скількома способами вони можуть
розподілитись між поверхами?
Вибір для кожної людини на якому поверсі
вийти не залежить від вибору іншої людини.
Давайте розв’яжемо цю задачу.
Знов таки, абсолютно схожі міркування.
Це я зобразив, вибачте, п’ятьох людей.
Для першого з них є 8
варіантів обрати де він виходить.
Для другого є вісім варіантів
обрати де він виходить.
Повторюю будь-який поверх з 2 по 9.
Таким чином, для кожної людини
існує рівно 8 варіантів вибору поверху
на якому він виходить.
А за основним правилом
комбінаторики – правилом множення,
ці числа треба перемножити
і ми одержуємо відповідь
вісім в п’ятому степені.
Наступна.
В мене на полиці стоїть
п’ять книжок, які я ще не читав.
Я збираюсь у відпустку.
Я дуже хочу з собою взяти щось почитати.
Скільки варіантів для мене обрати набір
з книжок, які я буду читати у відпустці?
Я можу взяти одну книжку,
я можу взяти будь-яку кількість
книжок від одного до п’яти.
Зрозуміло, що достатньо легко порахувати
скільки в мене способів взяти одну книжку
рівно 5 способів.
Можна порахувати скільки в
мене способів взяти 2 книжки.
Складніше, звісно.
Скільки способів взяти 3 і так далі.
Все це можна порахувати,
все це можна додати.
Ми одержимо, очевидно, правильну
відповідь, якщо не зробимо помилок.
Але я хотів розповісти про
трошки інше міркування.
Головна ідея комбінаторики полягає в тому,
що ми шукаємо взаємно
однозначну відповідність.
Якщо нам якісь об’єкти
порахувати достатньо важко,
от, найцікавіша історія в
комбінаториці - це придумати,
як замість цих об’єктів порахувати
якісь інші, які нам рахувати простіше.
Ну, я завжди люблю такий приклад.
Припустимо, прийшов до мене на
урок якийсь дуже непосидючий клас.
Я їх на перерві хочу порахувати,
а вони бігають, бігають і я
не знаю як їх порахувати.
Я спіймаю двох, а інші бігають.
І тут я розумію, що
насправді я ж точно знаю,
що кожен з цих учнів прийшов з портфелем.
І замість того, щоб рахувати
оці голови, які бігають по кабінету,
я краще порахую портфелі.
Власне кажучи, заміна одних
об’єктів іншими, які рахувати простіше –
оце і є найцікавіше і
найважливіше в комбінаториці.
Ще раз – можна рахувати всі варіанти
для однієї книжки, двох, трьох і так далі.
Але я пропоную зовсім інший підхід.
Я перенумерую книги.
І от я дивлюсь на них, я дивлюсь
на першу книжку і скажу так –
я її можу взяти, а можу не взяти.
Другу книжку … Тобто, для мене є
два варіанти вибору для цієї книги
я її беру, чи не беру.
Для другої книжки – аналогічно.
Можу взяти, можу не взяти.
Зрозуміло, що те саме
стосується кожної книги.
Для кожної книги в мене
існує два варіанти дій:
я її або беру з собою,
або не беру з собою.
За правилом множення –
ми це все маємо перемножити
і ми, нібито, одержуємо відповідь.
Насправді, слід не поспішати, а після
цього слід згадати всі умови задачі:
я хочу взяти будь-яку
кількість книжок від 1 до 5.
Я порахував, що в мене, насправді,
існує 32 варіанти вибору множин книжок.
Але, якщо будемо уважними, помітимо,
що серед цих варіантів є зайвий –
я можу не взяти першу книжку, я можу
не взяти другу, третю, четверту, п’яту.
Серед цих тридцяти
двох варіантів є ось такий.
Він нас не влаштовує,
тому що ми домовились,
що якусь книжку я все таки маю взяти.
Отже, ми порахували, що
всіх можливих варіантів 32.
Серед них є один зайвий, тому
остаточна відповідь в нашій задачі –
31 варіант у мене є взяти
з собою набір книжок.
Я хочу результат цієї
задачі трішки узагальнити.
Нагадую, що існує поняття
“підмножина деякої множини”.
Ми будемо казати, що множина
“В” є підмножиною множини “А”,
якщо кожен елемент множини В є
одночасно елементом множини А.
За допомогою діаграм Ейлера це
можна зобразити ось таким чином.
Існує домовленість, що порожня множина,
тобто, множина, яка не
містить жодних елементів,
є підмножиною будь-якої множини і
сама множина є підмножиною самої себе.
Тут виникає природне питання: якщо
множина складається з “N” елементів,
скільки в неї підмножин?
Давайте якісь розглянемо випадки.
Ну, припустимо, “N” дорівнює 2.
Множина складається з
двох елементів: “А” і ”В”.
Давайте просто підрахуємо
всі підмножини цієї множини.
Порожня множина, підмножина
може складатись з одного елемента –
це може бути “А”,
це може бути ”В” і, врешті решт,
сама множина є підмножиною себе.
Ми одержали, що кількість
підмножин дорівнює 4.
Зрозуміло, що для будь-якого “N”
вести підрахунок аналогічним
способом достатньо важко.
Тому давайте подумаємо
– як його спростимо.
І отут нам на допомогу
прийдуть міркування,
які я застосував у задачі про книжки.
Якщо множина складається з “N” елементів,
я перенумерую елементи цієї множини.
Отже, кожна підмножина
складається з елементів цієї множини.
От я конструюю підмножину.
Я скажу, що перший елемент я можу включити
в цю підмножину, а можу не включити.
Другий елемент я можу включити в
цю підмножину, а можу не включити.
Виходить, що для кожного елемента в
мене існує рівно два варіанти вибору дії:
я його або включаю в цю
підмножину, або не включаю.
За правилом множення, всі
ці двійки треба перемножити.
Двійок у нас “N” штук і ми одержуємо
наступний дуже важливий результат:
кількість підмножин множини,
яка складається з “N” елементів,
дорівнює 2 в степені “N”.
Як бачите, в нашому прикладі ми одержали
відповідь, яка цьому не суперечить.
Це дуже важливий результат,
який ми ще в нашому курсі згадаємо.
Він нам знадобиться.
Ну, мабуть, остання на сьогодні задачка.
Є футбольна команда. У
футбольній команді – 11 людей,
треба обрати капітана, треба
обрати заступника капітана.
Скількома способами ми можемо це зробити?
Давайте порахуємо. Знов таки, все легко.
Скільки існує способів обрати капітана?
У нас 11 гравців, 11 способів
обрати капітана, зрозуміло.
Капітан вже обраний. Він відійшов вбік.
Скільки в нас існує способів
обрати заступника капітана? 10
Для кожного вибору капітана
існує 10 способів обрати заступника.
Отже, це число – кількість
варіантів дорівнює 110.
Ще раз. Ми сьогодні розглянули два
дуже важливих правила комбінаторики,
базових правил комбінаторики:
правило множення, правило додавання.
Ми потренувались як їх
застосовувати в задачах.
Це база. За допомогою цієї бази
ми будемо одержувати дуже важливі,
дуже цікаві результати. Але це
вже буде на наступних уроках.
Дякую! До побачення!